now this week china imposed sanctions on
10
uk organizations and individuals for
spreading what it calls
lies and disinformation about human
rights abuses now the sanctions hit
five conservative mps including the
former minister
mr ghani who joins us now and what
happened
well it's a curious state of affairs
sophie a number of us were
sanctioned and i think that chinese
communist parties thought that they were
intimidating us or were going to stop us
talking about gross human rights abuses
particularly
in xinjiang but it's been a complete
misstep by the chinese communist party
it's done a couple of things instead
it's actually made parliament come
together
and say we won't have democratically
elected officials intimidated anyway
it's also sophie given us an opportunity
to talk about the one thing
the chinese communist party do not want
us to talk about which is the gross
human rights abuses against the uyghur
people and the fact that a genocide has
been called out
against china on the way that they're
treating the weaker people by many
countries around the world
you of course spoken out very strongly
about some of those human rights
abuses i just wonder if you feel that
the uk government has been tough enough
in its dealings with china
if you look at for example the
integrated defense review published a
couple of weeks ago
it calls for a positive trade and
investment relationship
with china given the treatment of the
uyghurs given the situation in hong kong
given the fact this is a country that
has sanctioned british mps
is that really good enough well we must
remember these sanctions are in
retaliation for the uk government
sanctioning chinese officials who have
been
implicated in the gross human rights
abuses so the uk government is
definitely in the right direction we
would ask
many of us colleagues will ask that the
uk government goes even further
and sanctions even more chinese
officials who are involved in the abuses
in
xinjiang and what's also come about
because of the sanctions sophie
a greater discussion about where we
stand
in the new global order if the chinese
communist party is going to be using
both its
financial power through its belt and
road initiative and also
using these so-called sanctions to try
and silence individuals like myself
i think these sanctions are a turning
point in how we consider our long-term
relationship
with china but not just us individually
just the uk but also working with our
partners countries like america for
example
i think this is a moment that i don't
expect the chinese communist party
wanted to come about because of the
sanctions
but we now have an opportunity to think
about are we going to assert our values
and how we're going to do that
now boris johnson hosted the mps had
been sanctioned
yesterday in downing street couldn't
help but notice that tom tuggenheim
wasn't there
the chair of the foreign affairs select
committee who also was sanctioned
um he tweeted to say he wasn't invited
do you know what happened the meeting
was organized
um very quickly um at the last minute
because the sanctions came about over
overnight on thursday we were made aware
of them on friday and the meeting came
about very quickly
on on saturday but look all of us
colleagues
were sanctioned for doing what we've
been elected to do
which so was he invited do you know we
were all invited at very
very um last minute sophie but what's
what's critical here is that we met with
the prime minister and the prime
minister's standing
side by side with us which i don't think
was the outcome the chinese communist
party thought they were going to achieve
with the sanctions i assume they thought
that we would be
marginalized by our party and that we
will then feel intimidated in talking
about the abuse of the uyghur
but that definitely is not what has
happened just feels bit strange
you know that he tweeted to say he
wasn't invited he wasn't there he's
obviously one of the most high profile
critics of china and the uyghurs you
know it'd be pretty bad look obviously
for the prime minister to be speaking
free speech but not inviting tom tugan
perhaps because of things that he said
so for the best of your knowledge that's
not the case he was invited
people were invited at very last minutes
i mean another parliamentary colleague
was in leicestershire
wasn't able to get down in time um but
the story here sophie is that we are
not going to be intimidated we're
continuing to speak about the abuse of
the weaker and we now have an even
closer relationship with the officials
in our government whether it's with the
prime minister or whether it's the
foreign secretary who are going to be
even more vocal because of the meeting
that took place yesterday
and the statements the foreign secretary
made so whatever outcome the chinese
communist party thought they were going
to achieve with sanctioning
elected officials that definitely hasn't
happened and all we've been able to do
is talk about the abuse
of the uyghur and if i have a moment
sophie is talking about two million
people that are in prison camps
in xinjiang and it is an issue for us
because they are forced into labor
and those products eventually earned up
on our shelves here in the uk
yeah a really important point to get
across and it's pretty clear from
speaking to you that the sanctions are
not going to
silence you if that is the aim and just
very finely while i have you
and we're talking about the road map out
of lockdown
the government asked parliament to
extend the emergency code restrictions
for another
six months earlier this week and you
abstained in that vote
um why did you abstain well we know that
the road map concludes towards the end
of
june and you know the government's doing
a fantastic job on that but there was a
particular
issue within the legislation which is
that the powers were to extend
up to october which is three months
beyond the road map and
i just felt that that was unnecessary
there was every opportunity
for parliamentarians to come back to the
house and for the executives to put
forward their position
and for that debate to take place we
know that the roadmap will will conclude
in a couple of months time of course the
government needs flexibility
but i just thought it was unnecessary
for for those rules and regulations
those powers that exist elsewhere in
other bits of legislation
to be in position for three months
beyond um the roadmap but look
um you know in in sussex we've had one
million people vaccinated so i'm just
really pleased that the vaccination
program is going incredibly well
and we're getting towards the end of um
this covered
lockdown and we'll be out of it by the
end of june yeah you can meet up with
five other people outside from tomorrow
it will be incredible very exciting news
and nisra garnier thank you very much
for being on the program today thank you
thank you